hey this is pressure Locker what is the
expected number of coin flips until you
get two heads in a row also what is the
expected number of coin flips until you
get a heads followed by a tails give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching the video for the solution
at first glance it would appear that
these two questions would have the same
answer after all if you flip a coin two
times the probability of getting H H is
exactly equal to the probability of
getting HT which is 25% but that's the
puzzling part the expected number of
coin flips for HT + HH are not the same
let's try and understand why let's first
imagine we're flipping to 2 heads in a
row on the first flip of the coin we can
either get a head or we can get a tails
we will now track where we go for each
subsequent flip if we flipped a tails on
our first toss there's a 50% chance that
we will flip tails again and remain in
that state there is also a 50% chance
that we will flip heads and transition
into the state of having flipped heads
if we're in the state of having flipped
heads there's a 50% chance we will flip
tails and go to the state of having
flipped tails and there's a 50% chance
that we will get another heads which
will bring us to two heads in a row now
each of these arrows represents the
transition probability of 50% because
each arrow has the same transition
probability of 50% I will simply omit
the numbers so that the diagram is
easier to read now we have an
understanding of the States in order to
get two heads in a row
now let's consider a similar diagram if
we're flipping to a heads followed by a
tails on our first flip we can either
get a heads or a tails if we flip a
tails on our first toss there's a 50%
chance we'll flip another tails and
there's a 50% chance that we'll flip
ahead and transition to the state of
having flipped a heads if we're in the
state of having flipped a heads there's
a 50% chance that we will flip another
heads and stay in that state and there
is a 50% chance that we will transition
and get a tails and so we'll have a
heads followed by a flip of a tails now
let's compare this diagram to the states
when we're trying to flip to two heads
in a row you'll notice that these two
diagrams are not the same and that
should suggest to you that the expected
number of flips to these two outcomes
might be different in fact these
diagrams suggest that it's going to take
fewer flips to get two heads followed by
tails to see why you will always need to
flip a heads before you get to the
outcome you want when you're flipping to
a heads followed by a tails there's a
50% chance that you will flip a heads
and remain in that state or there's a
50% chance that you will flip and get a
tails and then go to HT so you are
either going to go to the winning state
or you're going to stay in the state of
heads if you're trying to flip to two
heads on the other hand there's a 50%
chance that you will flip another heads
and you'll get to the winning state but
there's also a 50% chance that you will
go backwards and flip a tails so you'll
end up going to another state you're not
going to be in the state that's one away
from winning the outcome you want so
intuitively we can guess that'll take
fewer flips to get two heads
followed by tails now let's prove it we
want to calculate the expected number of
flips until we get a heads followed by a
tails on our first flip we're either
going to get two heads or tails so we
are then going to have one plus the
expected number of flips from each of
those states mathematically it's written
as one toss for the first house we're
going to make plus we want the
probability of flipping a head times the
expected number of flips from the state
of having flip two heads and we want the
probability of flipping a tails times
the expected number of flips from the
state of having flipped a tails the
probability of flipping heads and tails
are both equal to 50% so what remains is
to calculate the expected number of
flips from the state of having heads and
from the state of having tails so let's
calculate the expected number of flips
to get to HT if we're already in the
state of H there are two things that can
happen there's a 50% chance that we
remain in the state of heads in which
case we've basically wasted one flip or
there's a 50% chance that we flip a
tails and we get to the winning state of
HT we can simplify this expression
because the probability of H and the
probability of tails is 50% we now have
an equation in one variable which is the
expected number of flips from the state
of heads we can solve this equation and
get the expected number of flips to HT
from H is equal to two we'll do a
similar thing and calculate the expected
number of flips from the state of T
there's a 50% chance that we'll remain
in the state of tails and there's a 50%
chance we'll go to the state of heads in
which case we'll have the expected
number of flips from being in the state
of heads so we know the expected number
of flips from the state of heads is
equal to 2 and we can
to that quantity in we now have an
equation in one variable which is the
expected number of flips from the state
of tails we can therefore solve this
equation that the expected number of
flips from the state of tails is equal
to 4 we now can substitute these two
quantities into our original equation
and we can solve that the expected
number of flips to HT is equal to 4 so
on average it'll take us four flips to
have a heads followed by tails now let's
solve the other question how many flips
it will take to get to two heads in a
row on our first flip we're either going
to get two heads or tails with 50%
probability each we then need to
calculate the expected number of flips
from each state having flipped two heads
and having flipped a tails this problem
will be a little more complicated but
it'll be a similar approach if we
flipped a heads there's a 50%
probability that we're going to go flip
another heads and we'll get to our state
of H H and there's a 50% chance that
we'll flip the tails in which case we're
kind of going backwards and we'll need
to know the expected number of flips
from the state of having tails either
case is equally likely well simplify
this equation a bit but now an equation
that involves the expected number of
flips from the state of tails so let's
try and solve for that equation if
you're on tails there's a 50% chance
that you can stay there and there's a
50% chance that you're going to go to
heads so we'll write out that equation
we're going to use one toss to either
get to the same state of tails or we're
going to use 1 toss to get to the state
of heads in which case we have the
expected number of tosses from being in
heads we can simplify this expression
and we end up with an equation that
involves the state of heads so we now
have two equations in two variables we
can substitute our first equation the
expected number of tosses from the state
of heads into our second equation and
then we can solve for both variables we
end up with the expected number of
tosses from the state of heads is four
and the expected number of tosses from
the state of tails is six we can
substitute this back into our original
equation and we're going to get that the
expected number of flips until we see
two heads in a row is equal to six so
it'll actually take two more flips to
see two heads in a row then it will take
to see a heads followed by a tails now
there's one more thing we can do imagine
in our proofs we always replace the
letter H with the letter T and the
letter T with the letter H this will
basically allow us to solve for the
expected number of flips until we get to
tails in a row and the expected number
of flips until we get a tails followed
by a heads so if we make those
substitutions we can similarly find out
that it'll take six tosses to get two
tails in a row and it'll take four
tosses to get a tails followed by a
heads did you figure this problem out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel I make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on Facebook Google+ and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at pressure Locker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
links in the video description